durch sowas ist cool aus mit hallo ihr
lieben heute gibt es mal ein lover video
das habe ich so in der form noch nicht
gemacht aber es war jetzt einfach mal
dringend notwendig ihr stellt mir immer
eine frage wie hältst du dich fit wie
hast du so viel energie schaffst du es
dein alltag zu meistern
ich muss dazu sagen als selbständige ist
der alltag manchmal nicht so einfach man
hat einen arbeitstag von 16 stunden man
wacht mitarbeit auf und man geht mit
arbeit schlafen das ist nun mal so und
da muss man auch man sagt so die ersten
drei jahre durch bis sich alles so ein
bisschen normalisiert und im moment ist
es bei uns auch sehr stressig aber ich
empfinde es erstmal so blöd an aber ich
empfinde ist jetzt nicht als schlimmen
stress sondern ich mache das ja alles
für mein baby für meinen online shop für
meine produkte auf meine videos und für
die community halten das ist so das was
mich manchmal so ein bisschen runter
bringen aber das eigentliche worüber ich
heute mit euch reden will ist mein
schwarzkümmelöl denn ich habe euch vor
einem jahr oder vor über einem jahr
schon immer wieder erzählt dass ich
schwarzkümmelöl einnehme und mir das
wirklich hilft dass ich einfach fit und
vital bin und ich möchte jetzt erstmal
zurück gehen in der geschichte damals
dabei ich zwölf da wurde bei mir die
schilddrüsenunterfunktion diagnostiziert
ich bin mit meiner mama zum hausarzt
weil ich immer dauer meter war ich war
immer müde ich brauchte elf bis zwölf
stunden schlaf nach der schule dann noch
im mittagsschlaf und ich war einfach
antriebslos schwach hatte einfach keine
lust auf gar nichts und ist sich gezogen
über zehn jahre wenn nicht sogar mehr
und ich habe das sehr negativ in
erinnerung weil ich will gar nicht müde
sein ich möchte mich müde sein ich
möchte anpacken und machen um tun aber
ich bin immer sehr müde und antriebslos
gewesen bei einer
schilddrüsenunterfunktion ist es so dass
man wirklich antriebslos und müde und
schwach ist meistens friert man dann
auch schnell und bei einer
schilddrüsenüberfunktion ist das
gegenteil der fall dann ist man
hyperaktiv ist aber auch nicht immer gut
wenn mein herzrasen bekommen aber es ist
halt eine volkskrankheit und wert von
euch das frage ich jetzt mal direkt hat
denn eine
größen unterfunktion und schreibt mir
dann mal eure symptome auf ich glaube
das gleicht sich komplett also man ist
einfach total müde und ich hab dann
irgendwann das waren wirklich über zehn
jahre dienst land gezogen sind jemand
habe ich ein hamster kennengelernt oder
wir uns verlobt mal geheiratet und eine
hamza ist aber ich beobachte den immer
schwarzkümmelöl genommen und dann habe
ich ja warum nimmst du das immer und er
sagt hamza hat auch so eine lebenslauf
also ein lebenslauf mit heuschnupfen
hinter der kamera übrigens heute auch
wenn sich die kamera
du kannst sehen was hast du denn alles
gehabt bevor die allergien
hausstauballergie heuschnupfen
pigmentflecken ganz schlimm waren auch
schlafstörungen das war ganz schlimm ich
denke das kam auch vom stress und andere
sachen jetzt wie so schlimm sind wie
trockene haut etc und haben so hat es
also eigentlich haben sie mich überzeugt
wer den herrn so überzeugt hat was
erzähle ich euch gleich in aller ruhe
aber haben sie hat dann halt regelmäßig
eingenommen die pigmentflecken waren weg
er hat sich sogar eingerieben damit am
oberarm vor allem haben sie richtig
aussehen mit seinen pigmentflecken also
ich würde meinen aber es war echt heftig
und wieso sind ja das darf natürlich wie
sie sagen
auf jeden fall sind sie weg aber was ich
jetzt viel wichtiger finde heuschnupfen
hausstaub keine anzeichen komplett weg
was auch heftig ist aber es müsste wir
haben soll ich eigentlich erzählen sind
die polypen in der nase er war beim arzt
und hat dann eine cd gemacht richtig
beim hno und cd gemacht und er sollte
operiert werden aber haben sie ist ein
mensch der sich operieren lassen und
danach etwas kümmel öl eingenommen
teilweise auch eingerieben und dann ist
ja noch mal hin hatten cd gemacht und
der arzt hat gesagt das habe ich noch
nie gesehen
kriege ich die erlaubnis von ihm dass
ich das meine ärzte kollegen und
kolleginnen zeige und haben gesagt ja
kein problem und die op war vom tisch so
und dadurch das haben wir solche erfolge
erlebt hat habe ich gesagt weißt du was
ich möchte das auch nehmen muss jetzt
dazu sagen der hamza ist so einer wenn
er von etwas überzeugt ist dann steht
der zu 100 prozent dahinter
ich bin sehr schwer zu überzeugen ich
bin sehr schwer zu überzeugen aber als
istanbul hamza gesehen habe
und dann noch die vorgeschichte
überhaupt gehört warum nimmt haben sie
jetzt schwarzkümmel wie kommt er
es gibt so viele öle auf der welt warum
ausgerechnet schwarzkümmelöl und warum
die olivenöl es gibt eine überlieferung
im islam
da sagt der prophet muhammad friede und
sehen sie auf ihm er sagt im
schwarzkümmelöl gibt es heilung für
alles außer für den tod und das das kann
man jetzt interpretieren und analysieren
aber es ist einfach so ein zeichen für
uns okay da muss irgendetwas gutes bei
sein
es gibt natürlich einmal die religion
und einmal die wissenschaft und die
wissenschaft hat es schon mehrmals
belegt ich habe euch auch studien in die
infobox angehängt mehrmals belegt wie
gut das schwarzkümmelöl ist was für
nährstoffe enthalten sind und vitamine
und dann möchte ich jetzt auch im
einzelnen darauf eingehen ich muss aber
dazu sagen
die liste ist so lang ich beschränke
mich jetzt so oft das wichtigste und auf
das essentielle und ich könnte
eigentlich wirklich drei stunden über
schimmel reden aber ich möchte das für
die auch nicht zu langatmig machen fakt
ist heute also stand heute nehme ich das
schwarzkümmelöl seit zwei jahren ein
und ich habe die letzten zwei jahren die
letzten zwei jahre waren die
stressigsten zeiten in meinem leben ich
arbeite schon seit ich 16 bin also
sowieso beigebracht und immer gearbeitet
für unser taschengeld
ob es bei uns um einen kaffee war eine
tankstelle im callcenter immer nebenbei
gearbeitet aber was sie jetzt machen mit
kies kitchen selbstständigkeit das ist
noch mal ein ganz anderes level das kann
man mit all dem anderen gar nicht
vergleichen und stress löst so viel aus
und ich hatte so viel stress in den
letzten zwei jahren ich bin froh dass
ich ausgerechnet dann auch mit dem
schwarzkümmelöl angefangen habe weil es
mir tatsächlich auch sehr sehr sehr viel
geholfen hat in solchen zeiten
ich merke auch wenn ich die einnahme
vergesse man muss halt auch regelmäßig
einnehmen wenn ich die vergesse da merke
ich dass mir etwas fehlt und ich möchte
jetzt wie gesagt auf die einzelnen
elemente eingehen was es sagt was es
beinhaltet wo es alles anwenden können
indem schwarzkümmelöl
sind vitamine enthalten reichlich
vitamine vitamin b1 b2 b6 vitamin c
vitamin e ich kann die liste es wirklich
endlos lang ich schreibe es euch auch
noch mal in die video beschreibung fakt
ist im moment ist es ja so dass viele
nahrungsergänzungsmittel nehmen die
termine die ergänzend sind nehmen wenn
ihr das schwarzkümmelöl nimmt dann fällt
eine vielzahl davon weg man hat erstens
weniger verpackungsmüll zweiten muss man
halt weniger einnehmen und hat alles in
einem
und drittens ist ja nicht nur sind ja
nicht nur vitamine enthalten sondern
auch noch viel viel viel mehr zu
mineralstoffe sind enthalten zink
magnesium seelen also alles auch für
haut und haare darauf komme ich aber
gleich noch zu sprechen denn es ist
nicht nur eine moonboots da sag ich mal
sondern auch wirklich was fürs
äußerliche ich glaube soll cleopatra hat
in schwarz grün gebadet
apropos haut und haare biotin ist
enthalten eine zeit lang habe ich aus
dem drogeriemarkt tabletten genommen mit
biotin weil ich wollte dass meine haare
schneller wachsen und im schwarzkümmelöl
ist halt auch nur säure enthalten das
ist eine essentielle fettsäure das heißt
ihr könnt also der körper kann die nicht
selber herstellen
die ist wichtig für den omega 3 omega-6
haushalt man sollte ja eigentlich
omega-3 zu omega 6 so ein gleichgewicht
haben wir nehmen aber im alltag viel
mehr omega 3 zu uns als omega 6 und
damit habt ihr halt auch noch mal so ein
ausgleich und ihr werdet euch dann auch
körperlich und seelisch besser fühlen
wichtig ist natürlich einfach auch das
ist regelmäßig einem die ich gerade
schon sagte wenn ihr aufhört oder wenn
ihr das jetzt in dem sitzen monat ein
regelmäßig und dann eine woche wieder
nicht das gleiche wie zb mit meinen
schilddrüse tabletten die muss ich auch
immer einnehmen und nicht irgendwie
monat nämlich eine woche höre ich dann
wieder auch also eine regelmäßige
einnahme ist sehr sehr wichtig ich
wiederhole das deshalb so oft im video
weil ihr das wirklich beachten muss
nämlich schade dass wenig einnimmt und
dem bleibt okay euch gehts besser und
ihren damit aufhört das ist okay jetzt
jetzt fehlt mir wieder was
deshalb sage ich das so oft damit ihr
das auch wirklich beachtet so nächstes
thema die weißen blutkörperchen das
haben wir alle in der schule schon
gelernt die weißen blutkörperchen die
machen sich stark wenn sich tumore
bilden et cetera und schwarzkümmelöl
stärkt die weißen blutkörperchen das
heißt sie können noch besser aktiv
werden falls sich tumore bilden
ganz wichtig auch in der krebsbehandlung
da wird immer mehr schwarzkümmelöl jetzt
auch eingesetzt ich habe leider in
meiner familie einen ganz jungen fall
von krebs und das erste was ich gemacht
habe ist eine packung schwarzkümmelöl
geschickt zu haben dass das erste was
ich gemacht habe es kann schmerzlindernd
seien bei der chemotherapie
wie gesagt es kämpft gegen tumore an
natürlich kann man nicht sagen man ist
komplett vom krebs geheilt aber man
denke sich ja auch wenn ich das
schwarzkümmelöl nicht einnehme wie
schlimm wäre dann der verlauf dann oder
wie schlimm wäre der tumor dann also
lieber nehme ich doch ein und weiß okay
das hilft mir als wenn ich komplett
darauf verzichte und es wirkt eben auch
vorbeugend neben dem heuschnupfen was
ich gerade schon angeschnitten habe was
der haben sehr hatte hat schwarzkümmelöl
auch eine positive wirkung auf asthma
patienten die studie werde ich euch auch
in die video beschreibung 1 für mich
gerne mal durch falls ihr betroffen seid
falls ihr unter bluthochdruck leidet
oder jemanden kennt falls ihr sodbrennen
hat mein vater ist ein dauerpatient
rennen angeht er nimmt jetzt auch seit
einem jahr das schwarzkümmelöl und merck
deutliche besserung bei durchfall
blähungen immer regelmäßig
schwarzkümmelöl einnehmen fakt ist ja
auch damals wenn ich eine erkältung
hatte dann war ich mindestens fünf tage
weg vom fenster
wenn ich heute als selbständige fünf
tage lang krank bin einfach also fünf
tage wahlkampf sein bedeutet arbeit
bleibt liegen und stapelt sich ich habe
verdienstausfälle was man auch so sagen
muss ich kann keine videos drehen
ich kann man die community nicht
versorgen ich kann für die mitarbeiter
im shop nicht da sein also fünf tage
ausfall ist bei mir schon echt herbe und
das habe ich ja seite schwarzkümmelöl
nehme eben nicht mehr wenn ich krank bin
dann bin ich auch krank klar
ich kenne sie sagen dass ich nie kann
bin man hat immer mal einen schnupfen
aber mir geht es nach zwei tagen
allerspätestens wieder gut und auch bin
ich auch nur einen tag mal ein bisschen
schlapp merke da kommt was im nächsten
tag kuriere ich mich noch ein bisschen
außen am dritten tag spätestens wenn ich
wieder topfit und damals war ich auch
wirklich alle zwei monate mal krank und
jetzt war ich das letzte mal krank ich
kann mich sogar gar nicht mehr dran
erinnern mich an einige mütter
angeschrieben
zyklisch adhs ich muss dazu sagen da
habe ich mich auch informiert ich habe
jetzt natürlich keine kinder und in
meiner familie gibt es auch kein fall
von ada ist aber schwarzkümmelöl kann
die konzentration steigern und auch
bezüglich adhs gibt es studien die sagen
schwarzkümmelöl ist für die therapie
besser geeignet als zum beispiel andere
konventionelle mittel die nebenwirkungen
sind beim schwarzkümmelöl jetzt auch
nicht so rüber einer medikamenten die
man einsetzen müsste es wirkt viel sand
da einige anfragen habe ich auch
bekommen bezüglich neurodermitis
schuppenflechte auch da hilft
schwarzkümmelöl definitiv da habe ich
jetzt auch mehrere erfahrungsberichte
gelesen und ich freue mich auch über
eure erfahrungsberichte also schreibt
mir schreibt mir jederzeit wenn ihr jede
krankheit habt irgendeine oder euch
irgendwie unwohl fühlt und die nimmt das
schwarzkümmelöl dann schreibt mir von
euren besserungen ich werde das dann
auch posten damit wir dann auch anderen
zeigen können wie trauer das leben wirkt
und jetzt kommt auch mal zu einem
anderen thema beauty leute beauty es ist
unglaublich das schwarzkümmelöl hilft
natürlich dass die haare wachsen
ich musste mittlerweile so oft muss ich
die spitzen schneiden damals wird immer
lange haare haben mittlerweile nicht
mehr aber damals habe ich immer
bestimmte tabletten aus der drogerie
genommen wo eben biotin voting drin ist
und das habe ich alles im lot kümmel das
heißt ich kann auch alles andere
verzichten
meine augenbrauen diese band früher
immer zappten mittlerweile wachsen die
mir auch also die die sprießen richtig
ja also jeder kennt sie ja der
vielleicht seine augenbrauen noch mal
anders in shape bringen möchte und
sacrow wächst aber nichts versucht's mit
schwarzkümmel den wimpern leute wimpern
ich weiß nicht wer das gesehen hat von
euch wäre mir auf instagram folgt er
weiß ich hatte mal ein fauxpas mit
meinen wimpern ich hatte dann war das
haben sie vorne von einem halben jahr
ich hatte keine wimpern mehr an jedem
auge nur noch drei und ich konnte in der
zeit keine aufträge an dem es auf mich
ganz schlimm ich habe geweint weil ich
sollte es kann auch nicht sein dass ich
mit sie wimpern alle rausgerissen habe
es zwar auch ganz blöder ganz blöder
beauty viel von mir das schwarzkümmelöl
sind die so schnell nachgewachsen meine
freundin hatte zum fast gleichen
zeitpunkt das gleiche problem sie hat
kein schwarz-grün öl genommen und das
hat mega lange gedauert bis die
nachwachsen und ja mittlerweile
würde sich auch gar kein serum mehr so
ein serum kostet ja auch mega vielen er
braucht keinen wimpern museum in broken
augenbrauen serum was dazu sagen muss
was hilft nicht bei erblich bedingtem
haarausfall so muss ich auch fairerweise
sagen aber wenn ihr wenn ihr merkt durch
stress oder einfach durch vielleicht
falsche pflege habt ihr haare verloren
dann nimmt schwarzkümmel ihnen vertraut
denn sie werden sprießen wie gras aus
dem boden ist wirklich so erblich
bedingten haarausfall kann es natürlich
den ausfall verlangsamen aber erwartet
da keine wunder da bin ich auch ganz
offen und ehrlich mit euch andere sache
nehmt eure creme ihr müsst doch gar
keine creme nehmen ich mach das auch so
dass ich ein zwei mal die woche wirklich
schwarzkümmel in die handinnenflächen
nehme so ein paar tropfen und mir dann
ins gesicht schmieren
ich nehme es aber auch in meine
tagescreme also ich gebe die tropfen
immer eine tagescreme und immerhin
shampoo tatsächlich benutzt ist für die
haarpflege gibt eine getroffene neuer
shampoo vertraut mir und was ja auch
machen könnt das mache ich nach dem
haarewaschen dann nehme ich mir in die
in das handtuch trockene haar so ein
paar tropfen schwarzkümmelöl gibt das da
rein und ich merke richtig wie dick und
wie geschmeidig die dadurch sehen und
meine haare sind jetzt mehrfach gefärbt
und gerade bei mir ich habe ja dunkle
haare und hier sehr blondiert und das
eigentlich mega schlecht für die haare
aber ich wollte immer vor also ich mache
mir da keine gedanken weil das
schwarzkümmelöl das schützt noch mal so
ein bisschen was sie auch machen müsst
wenn die pickel habt schwarzkümmelöl
draufschreiben macht es einfach macht es
vertraut mir
ihr braucht das ganze clearasil zeug
nicht nimmt das schwarzkümmelöl man sagt
dem schwarzkümmelöl sogar nach dass es
für weiße zähne sorgt und so langsam
weil ich trinke am tag so viel kaffee
ich trinke das auch wirklich pur ohne
strom oder so ich dachte da gar nicht
drauf das einzige was mache ich putze
mir regelmäßig die zähne mit irgendeiner
billig zahnpasta irgendeine die ich da
glatt ganz unten im regal finden aber
man sagt dass im schwarzkümmelöl nach
und ich glaube da ganz fest daran meine
zähne die müssten eigentlich so gelb
sein ich habe sie noch nie mädchen das
nicht bekommen regelmäßig nachrichten
von richtig was seine zähne bieten
lassen noch nie in meinem ganzen leben
mir ist übrigens später erst aufgefallen
als ich mal so die rückseite von meinem
kosmetikprodukten gewesen habe das
tatsächlich schwarzkümmelöl auch in
kosmetika drin ist teilweise auch
richtig
luxuskosmetik also warum warum kaufen
wenn man es auch selber einfach in die
handinnenflächen einfach ins gesicht
treiben kann
in die haarspitzen probiert einfach auch
so ich bin jetzt schon sehr gespannt auf
eure erfahrungsberichte was ihr euch
jetzt fragte was sind die nebenwirkungen
heraus die nebenwirkungen sind folgende
ihr müsst euch vorstellen
die inhaltsstoffe sind hochkonzentriert
in dieser flasche wenn ihr jetzt auf
einmal ihr beginnt jetzt und dem
direkten esslöffel dann könnt ihr wissen
dann könnt ihr aufstoßen das sind so
jetzt die nebenwirkungen die meiner
meinung nach absolut nicht schlimm sind
aber was ich sozusagen muss ganz wichtig
in diesem video
schwangere sollten erstmal auf die
einnahme verzichten weil es einfach zu
jetzt zu den führen könnte und ihr
möchte das nicht also böse sammeln
höchstens am ende der schwangerschaft
mit absprache eures arztes aber während
der schwangerschaft würde ich definitiv
drauf verzichten mit sicherheit habe ich
hier 80 prozent an positiven
eigenschaften des schwarzkümmelöl nicht
aufgelistet
das ist einfach ein thema das ist ein
studium für sich ich habe euch so die
die für mich am interessantesten sind
aufgezählt ich werde aber immer wieder
in den kommentaren aktiv sein egal wie
alt dieses video sein wird wir können
uns immer wieder in den kommentaren
austauschen ihr könnt mir fragen stellen
ich stehe euch mit bestem gewissen zur
verfügung und ganz wichtig noch zu
einnahme das interessiert jetzt
wahrscheinlich die meisten wie ist das
bei der einnahme als erwachsener würde
ich sagen beginnt mit einem teelöffel
der geschmack sage ich ganz ehrlich ist
jetzt nicht so gerne mag ist einfach ich
mag ja auch das ganze am anfang machte
ich das auch ganz gerne mit einem
teelöffel honig dazu mich daran zu
gewöhnen mittlerweile brauchst gar nicht
mehr
mittlerweile habe ich mich auch von
einem teelöffel am morgen gesteigert auf
einen teelöffel am morgen und einen
teelöffel am abend ihr könntet auch ein
esslöffel direkt am morgen dem oder
eines so viel am abend das ist
vollkommen euch überlassen
das öl ist immer besser als kapseln weil
es über die schleimhäute einfach besser
auch noch aufgenommen wird zusätzlich
einige sagen morgens die einer bekommt
ihn nicht so gut auf leeren magen das
kann natürlich sein jeder mensch ist
anders
daher nimmt sie gerne abends ein wenn
ihn empfindlich mann
wichtig ist hat nun die regelmäßigkeit
also wirklich täglich bei der einnahme
was kinder angeht und babys bei babys da
bin ich ganz ehrlich halte ich mich
komplett raus ich kann ich nur sagen wie
ich es machen würde wenn ich kinder
hätte dann würde ich denen aber im alter
von circa drei jahren würde ich den ein
vierter teelöffel geben und damit
zunehmenden alter steigern dann halben
teelöffel irgendwann wenn jugendliche
sind ein teelöffel so würde ich es
machen es gibt noch keine eu normen
dafür aber man muss es auch natürlich
immer individuell bestimmen sitzung ein
paar worte zur aktuellen situation und
speziell zu meinem schwarzkümmelöl ihr
wisst ja gerade in seinen vom corona
virus sollte man man sollte es
eigentlich immer aber gerade jetzt noch
verstärkt da sein immunsystem stärken
hier habt ihr natürlich alles in einer
flasche gerade vitamin c ist sehr sehr
wichtig das schwarzkümmelöl kann viren
beseitigen ist stärker immunsystem und
gerade zu dieser zeit solltet ihr auf
eine regelmäßige einnahme achten was
auch sehr wichtig ist es gibt eben auch
wie bei jedem anderen produkt solche und
solche qualität ich habe darauf geachtet
denn ihr wisst wenn ich ein produkt
rausbringe stehe ich nicht mit meinem
namen dahinter meinem gesicht meiner
ganzen persönlichkeit sondern einfach in
meinem ganzen leben also es hat sich
extrem an aber es ist so wenn ich euch
etwas anbietet dann muss es zu 1000%
stimmig sein die nie della sera das ist
der echte schwarzkümmel kommt aus
ägypten und wir achten darauf
kontrolliert biologischem anbau das ist
mir ganz wichtig was mir auch wichtig
war und das steht bei mir an erster
stelle ist dass die produktion in
deutschland stattfindet die
produktionshallen die sind gar nicht
weit von uns entfernt wir könnten wenn
jetzt die aktuelle situation mit dem
corona virus nicht gegeben wäre könnten
wir runter fahren und euch sogar
mitnehmen und das finde ich auch mal
ganz cool es ihr auch mal ein blick habt
das habt ihr sonst nicht sonst habt ihr
ein produkt im regal stehen und kauft es
und ihr vertraut blind und ich kann euch
da eben die hallen zeigen und das habe
ich auch vor wenn sich die situation
beruhigt mir war halt der biologische
anbau sehr sehr wichtig die kaltpressung
ist sehr wichtig ist es eine schonende
kaltpressung damit die vitamine auch
enthalten bleiben und ich kann mit
bestem gewissen sagen dass das das beste
schwarzkümmelöl ist was ich persönlich
je ein genommen habt so ich verabschiede
mich jetzt von euch ich hoffe dass euch
das video gefallen hat dass sich eure
fragen klären konnte wir schreiben natur
in den kommentaren miteinander wenn ihr
fragen habt dann schreibt sie mir wir
tauschen uns aus ich kann auch gerne
noch ein zweites video machen denn hier
ist bei weitem noch nicht alles gesagt
über das schwarzkümmelöl und ich glaube
wir werden in zukunft noch ganz ganz
ganz viel tolles erfahren ansonsten
wünsche ich euch noch einen
wunderschönen tag und wir sehen uns dann
bei meinem nächsten videos eure kind
[Musik]